Rafael aquí en el estudio de France 24
este tema migratorio sigue siendo una
deuda pendiente de la agenda de los
demócratas que están en la presidencia
en este momento pero tampoco los
republicanos votan muchas ideas al
interior del legislativo como para
ponerse de acuerdo en las agendas sobre
este tema tiene toda la razón Santiago y
hace parte de los temas tradicionales
que dividen los enfoques de republicanos
y de demócratas si bien los demócratas
ven una amenaza a la democracia en
términos generales en esta elección para
los republicanos y especialmente para
los republicanos del sur estamos
hablando de Florida estamos hablando de
Texas
declarar la emergencia por materia
migratoria era una cuestión fundamental
y el presidente wyden eligió un enfoque
distinto Cuál fue el enfoque que escogió
el enfoque que escogió fue nombrar a la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris como
representante del gobierno para que
desestimulara la llegada de inmigrantes
a través de la frontera Sur sendos
viajes a Centroamérica sendoviaje a
México pero eso no ha sido suficiente
los migrantes siguen llegando de hecho
se ha incrementado durante algunos meses
en lo corrido de estos dos años la
llegada de migrantes de manera ilegal y
eso sin duda alguna ha generado una
profunda división en especial en el
estado de la Florida y en el estado de
Texas pero hay uno en el cual todavía no
vamos a conocer resultados porque lo
vamos a conocer más tarde en la noche y
es el estado de Arizona clave porque se
juega la gobernación y se juega un
escaño dejado por el anterior senador
John McCain que falleció en el año 2019
lo gana el ex astronauta Kelly que es
esposo de Billy gilfort ha sido a
defensora de controles para
las armas para el porte de armas en los
Estados Unidos y el mismo tiempo que ha
plantado un enfoque relativamente
distinto al de mano dura en un Estado
Sureño como es el de Arizona vamos a ver
si resultados a los demócratas que
arañaron ese estado con con mucha
dificultad hace dos años lo pueden
retener y si eventualmente en otras
particularmente en la cámara en el sur
de Texas pueden volver a ser fuertes Por
qué los de los el tema migratorio
también ha generado especialmente como
una de satisfacción hacia los demócratas
porque cuando han ganado las elecciones
no han sido capaces de proponer en parte
por el bloqueo de los republicanos pero
también porque es difícil consensuar una
reforma migratoria encontrar el timing
político encontrar el timing en la de
repartición de El Congreso que satisfaga
los intereses tanto de unos como de
otros y creo que ahí sigue siendo un
tema de difícil solución y que sin duda
alguna es un debe para ambos partidos
tanto para el demócrata como para el
republicano